my name is Daniel : Ramos I am a cell
biologist at Yale University and my lab
in collaboration with Herreshoff at the
NIH and sear on Bao at sloan-kettering
recently developed a new very powerful
imaging technology that allows to
visualize with single-cell resolution
the development of an organism in its
entirety
this technology is called inverted
selective plane illumination microscopy
and is 30 times faster than the fastest
microscopes that are conventionally used
in the field we use a worm a nematode
that's called C elegans as a model
organism in this movie you're seeing an
embryo of C elegans as it's developing
with a conventional microscope we will
have to expose this embryo for 14 hours
of continuous illumination and that will
kill the animal because it will receive
too much light and it will burn our
microscope is much faster and exposes
the animal to less light therefore we
can visualize the entire development of
the animal without causing harm
moreover the speed of this microscope
now allows us to see events that were
never seen before for example in this
embryo we can actually visualize the
position of all cells you can see the
nuclei in red and then in green you're
seeing the positions of neurons those
neurons now we can tell where they're
born and where they're going where
they're gonna form connections where
they're gonna where their final
destination is going to be that allows
us to build an atlas of development for
this animal the atlas will be enormously
useful we really don't understand how
genes regulate how neurons come together
as a system in a whole animal to
assemble into circuits and regulate
behaviors genes are conserved through
our evolution if we were to understand
how genes are regulating this process in
the Atlas this will have huge
implications for research and it will
also influence the way that we think
about every disease imaginable